bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde on
dirait que j - 4 avant le premier tour
et dans cette émission comme chaque soir
un grand débat sur un grand thème de la
campagne
ce soir les salaires comment les
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat s'est
imposée comme la grande attente des
français il ya les mesures pour contenir
la hausse des prix mais au delà tous les
candidats font des propositions pour que
le travail paye mieux hausse du smic
baisse des cotisations incitation ou
négociations trois experts sur ce
plateau pour faire le tour à des
propositions et vous aider à faire votre
choix d'ici dimanche avec notre grand
témoin ce choix on va revenir sur la
guerre en ukraine la violence barbare de
l'armée russe et les images des
massacres de boudhha ont fait le tour du
monde et ont un tournant dans ce conflit
après ces crimes de guerre la réponse
des européens qui pourrait décider de se
passer du charbon rust soir est elle à
la hauteur et puis le pouvoir du kremlin
commence-t-il à se fissurer ces
questions va déposer à marie mendras
grande spécialiste de la russie avec
nous ce soir enfin dans le scan ce soir
l'éditorialiste thomas legrand va
revenir sur cet écart qui se resserre
tous les jours un peu plus entre marine
le pen et emmanuel macron la sémiologue
mariette darrigrand va nous parler d'un
mot très présent dans la bouche de
certains candidats ce mot c'est le cas
aux cocus l'oeil de blacko bien sûr le
carnet de campagne quotidien signé
stéphane blakowski voilà convenu c'est
parti
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à vous chers téléspectateurs
s'il ya une chose qui met d'accord tous
les candidats c'est que le travail ne
paie pas assez en france le retour de
l'inflation la pénurie de recrutement
dans certains secteurs ont fait du
pouvoir d'achat la première
préoccupation des français loin loin
devant toutes les autres alors comment
augmenter les salaires dans les
entreprises c'est notre question ce soir
bonsoir cyril chavagné pardonnez-moi si
riche à banier je regarde dans la
mauvaise direction vous êtes président
de la cftc confédération française des
travailleurs chrétiens
autant pour moi donc je vous connais
donc vous êtes du côté des syndicats des
salariés vous nous direz si les choses
changent avec les employeurs dans les
branches si le rapport de force est en
train de s'inverser bonsoir christophe
ramaux bonsoir moi si c'est vous
économiste vous enseignez à la sorbonne
et vous êtes membre des économistes
atterrés enfin bon soir béatrice mathieu
on serait revenu sur ce plateau vous
êtes la chef du service économie de
l'hebdomadaire l'express on sera tout à
l'heure à distance avec un patron parce
qu'il en faut quand même hein dans ce
débat ce sera franck delvaux le patron
de l'umih l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie qui peine à
recruter mais qui négocie et qui obtient
peut-être nous dira-t-il satisfaction
alors l'objectif de ce débat et bien
c'est d'y voir un peu plus clair dans
l'est dans les programmes qui est le
plus crédible pour obtenir des
entreprises devraient hausse de salaire
dans le privé la hausse du smic est elle
finalement un préalable indispensable
avant de vous laisser la parole on va
faire le tour d'horizon de qui propose
quoi sur les salaires avec marco premier
la hausse des salaires nerf de la guerre
du pouvoir d'achat à gauche on fait de
la hausse du smic une priorité
aujourd'hui à 1269 euros net par mois
anne hidalgo veulent augmenter de 200
euros jean luc mélenchon lui souhaite le
porter à 1400 euros 1500 pour fabien
roussel et pour yannick jadot je veux
immédiatement augmenter le smic à 1400
euros nets et le portèrent 1500 à la fin
du quinquennat mais en matière de
salaire minimum la palme revient à
philippe poutou et nathalie arthaud un
smic à 2000 euros net par mois c'est la
proposition choc de la candidate de
lutte ouvrière 2000 euros pour vivre oui
c'est ce qu'il faut voilà c'est ce qu'il
faut pour pas être dans l'angoissé
permanente de se retrouver dans
l'incapacité
de remplir son frigo de payer son loyer
emmanuel macron lui refuse tout coup de
pouce au smic sa mesure phare le
triplement de la prime macron jusqu'à
3000 euros par an à la discrétion des
employeurs prime défiscalisées et sans
charges patronales pour que le travail
paye mieux marine le pen veut exonérer
les moins de 30 ans de l'impôt sur le
revenu mais la candidate du
rassemblement national promet surtout
une hausse de 10% des salaires pour les
français gagnant jusqu'à 3 fois le smic
augmenté de 10% les salaires c'est aussi
la volonté de valérie pécresse + 3 % dès
l'été 2022 pour les rémunérations
inférieures à 2800 euros nets autre
proposition convertir ses rtt en salaire
et là aussi sans sans limites et ce sera
exonérée de charges patronales quant à
eric zemmour pour doper le pouvoir
d'achat le candidat ne prévoit pas
d'augmentation direct des salaires sa
mesure consiste à baisser la csg pour
les salariés gagnant jusqu'à 2000 euros
net par mois objectif rendre un
treizième mois aux français
voilà ce débat sur les bas salaires il
existait même avant à la guerre en
ukraine et avant l'inflation la forte
inflation qu'on connaît déjà et qui
risque d'augmenter il ya des pénuries de
recrutement dans certains secteurs alors
christophe ramaux on se dit ya urgence à
revaloriser les salaires aujourd'hui
lesquels précisément on parle vraiment
des bas salaires du smic est un peu plus
du smic oui tout à fait bien sûr il faut
revaloriser les bas et les moyens
salaires
et c'est bon pour l'économie il faut il
faut sortir de cette idée qui domine
depuis quarante ans et qui nous a
conduits de murs au mur quelle idée que
en comprimant sans cesse les salaires eh
bien ça va améliorer la compétitivité et
l'investissement les entreprises non
c'est faux il ya deux millions de
personnes au smic en france tout à fait
30 perd 30% des salariés sont à moins de
1,3 smic il faut changer cela et 56%
sont en dessous de 1,5 smic voyez ce que
je veux dire donc il faut réduire aussi
la hiérarchie des salaires
ça résoudrait pas tous les problèmes
j'ai entendu
des égards
le travail c'est un travail collectif
pour être motivé il faut avoir le
sentiment de faire partie d'un collectif
qu un patron du cac 40 gagne de l'ordre
de 15 à 20 millions euros par jour ça
brise ou exclus dire c'est pas en
réduisant ses rémunérations combat en
beauté le reste des salaires faut pas
mentir bien entendu mais il ya un
problème de contrat social et donc je
reviens sur ce que je disais cirque eux
mais nous vivons dans les sociétés
salariale 90% des gens qui travaillent
france aujourd'hui comme dans la com aux
etats-unis sont des salariés et donc ce
qu'on appelle le coût du travail mais
c'est le principal débouché aussi des
entreprises
mais la sexualité gérer la plus vraiment
proprement social de c'est le rôle de
l'état dans la puissance publique parce
que bien entendu si une entreprise tout
seul dans son coin elle augmente ses
salaires et que les concurrents font
exactement inverse vous avez bien
compris qu'elle va être difficulté qu'on
va venir delta donne l'impulsion
notamment à travers le smic en disant ya
besoin maintenant de revaloriser de
façon générale des salaires eh bien on
rentre dans un cercle vertueux y compris
pour la demande des entreprises va
parler du smic on va parler des
cotisations béatrice mathieu sur le
diagnostic ce problème des salaires est
ce qu'il est spécifique à la france où
aujourd'hui avec l'inflation qui touche
toute l'europe tous nos voisins le
connaissent aussi et il est même je
dirais même moins spécifique à la france
que certains de nos voisins européens ou
même anglo saxons d'une très forte
revalorisation en allemagne
si on regarde un peu historiquement ce
que les économistes appellent le partage
de la valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire dans
la richesse créée ce qui revient à
l'entreprise qui est investi skis et
redonner aux salariés il ya eu beau - de
déformation historiquement sur les 10 15
dernières années en france que dans
d'autres pays donc ce problème de
salaire il est moins cruciale en france
que chez nos voisins ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y en a pas et qu'il n'ya pas
évidemment un problème de bas salaires
mais c'est pas un problème spécifique à
la france là où il peut y avoir un
problème spécifique à la france est tout
seul
cet écrasement en fait des salaires au
niveau du smic est un petit peu au
dessus du smic lui aussi à une politique
qui a été menée depuis des années c'est
d'allègement et mettre presque de
suppression de toutes les charges
sociales au niveau jusqu'à 1,5 1,6 et un
système de trappe à bas salaires merci
de pas finalement on n'incite pas les
autres et là on en scène un site pas les
entreprises à faire en sorte que a
travaillé sur l'évolution des salaires
dans l'entreprise et faire en sorte que
ça dépasse les 1,6 smic dans la mesure
où elles payent davantage davantage de
alors de cotisation regardons un instant
les propositions puis je vous donne la
parole notamment sur le smic parce que
c'est quand même centrale dans ce débat
présidentiel pour faire simple toute la
gauche veut augmenter le smic on va
revoir les candidats ses 2400 euros nets
pour mélenchon jadot un peu plus pour
yann et dago jusqu'à anne hidalgo
jusqu'à de nathalie arthaud 2000 euros
nets à droite sans surprise on ne veut
pas augmenter le smic en revanche on
veut baisser les cotisations et là on va
voir à nouveau les candidats qui propose
ça valérie pécresse avec des modalités
un peu différente marine le pen eric
zemmour déjà qu'est-ce que ça traduit ce
clivage gauche-droite sur les salaires
ça traduit une différence idéologique où
on voit bien qu'à droite on s'accroche
sur le smic et à gauche à gauche c'est
déjà ça mais les gens smic et à droite
on sacrant s'accroche sur la baisse des
cotisations comme seul seul outil de
revenir de revalorisation décembre va
essayer de comprendre s'il ya des freins
qu'est ce qui pourrait au fond ralentir
cette proposition du smic pourquoi
certains l'attendent pourquoi pourquoi
d'autres disent ya d'autres moyens c'est
le sable et vous vous êtes syndicaliste
vous l'attendez cette hausse du smic au
fond le smic c'est le seul levier que
les pouvoirs publics ont
pour dire au moins voilà vous êtes on
vous impose un salaire minimum plus
élevé dans un contexte d'inflation est
ce que vous attendez cette mesure oui on
l'attend alors je sais pas tout à fait
d'accord pour dire que c'est la seule
mesure se lever en tout cas c'est
peut-être le plus en tout cas pour
l'état mais c'est le plus le plus direct
et le plus facile peut-être pour l'état
c'est évident qu'aujourd'hui et on
l'avait demandé nous la cftc qu'il
fallait un coup de pouce au smic en tout
cas la revalorisation parce ça ce que ça
ne s'arrête pas juste aux à l'inflation
de manière automatique avait demandé que
ça se fasse même en amont parce que vu
le taux de l'inflation on voulait que ça
arrive quelques mois avant elle le sait
qu'on va revoir en france
1269 euros net par mois il va être
revalorisée de 2 me pour cent à partir
du mois de mai ça va faire à peu près 30
euros de plus mais vous avez été
suffisant mais non c'est pas suffisant
il faut il faut faire en vrai coup de
pouce au smic et puis
il ya des études qui sont très précis
sur sa qui sont indépendantes qui
commence à dater d'ailleurs de quelques
années maintenant mais qui est qu'ils
avaient fait à peu près consensus pour
dire que une personne seule qui vit en
logement social d'envoyer on ne prend
pas quelqu'un très haut et qui est qui
dans une ville moyenne donc je mets un
dehors de paris le salaire décent pour
vivre il fallait 1450 euros
1450 euros c'est le salaire qui était
jugée décent pour vivre pour un salarié
donc je crois que par définition il faut
contents de leur peut-être pas en une
fois mais forcément il faut qu'on tende
au moins à ce salaire décent sinon pour
le syndicat comme le mien qui défend le
respect de la dignité de la personne et
que le travail paye décemment je vois
pas comment je pourrais aller en deçà du
salaire qui est dit par ses études des
angles donc c'est salutaire que cette
question du smic soit clairement
centrale en tout cas à gauche pour les
candidats dans la campagne je retiens ça
seul levier mais il faut augmenter le
smic bonsoir franck delvaux merci d'être
allégé vous présidez l'umih l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie on va parler dans un
instant des négociations et notamment
dans la restauration de l'hôtellerie qui
ont avancé on va voir si ça suffit ou
pas maintenant qu'on a encore plus
d'inflation mais sur le smic vous qui
est du côté des employeurs qu'est ce que
vous dites on entend souvent cette
petite musique attention si on augmente
le smic on va freiner l'embauchent
d'accord ou pas avec ça
je rejoins un peu ce qu'a dit monsieur
chabanier avant moi en dix ans il n'y a
pas que le smig aujourd'hui on peut
aussi libéralisé les heures
supplémentaires en les défiscalisant à
la fois à la fois sur le plan patronale
est à la fois sur les cotisations
salariales
nous on était dans une profession
l'hôtellerie la restauration ou notre
grille de salaires n'avait pas évolué
depuis maintenant deux ans et qu'il
fallait la faire bouger on est et on
avait été rattrapé par le fameux slip
donc il fallait effectivement qu'on
bouge et aujourd'hui on est en mesure de
proposer aux plus faibles et chiant de
notre grille un salaire horaire
largement au dessus de celui d'ismail
alors racontez nous un petit peu comment
se sont passées ces ces négociations
dans les entreprises dans les branches
on sait que dans la restauration en
moyenne les salariés ont obtenu 16%
d'augmentation et ça c'était avant la
guerre en ukraine donc avant les
chiffres de l'inflation qu'on a
aujourd'hui
il faut au fond avoir du mal à recruter
après la crise sanitaire pour enfin que
les patrons décident de mettre la main
au porte-monnaie
pas le dire comme ça effectivement il ya
un déficit de recrutement il déficit de
recrutement il existait déjà avant avant
lui qu vide pendant le covin de gris
n'avait pas évolué comme je les dis
avant le comique non plus ça n'avait pas
bougé puisqu'on avait pas d'accord et
donc fallu fallait que ça bouge un
moment ou un autre à les rendre un peu
plus d'attractivité pour notre
profession effectivement il était normal
en plus on est quand même un métier où
il ya des contraintes il ya des coupures
ont trahi le samedi on travaille le week
end trail les jours fériés donc à un
moment fallu faire bouger les choses
pour nous rappeler un peu les la teneur
des négociations 16% d'augmentation de
salaire en moyenne
mais pour les plus bas salaires c'est
beaucoup moins
alors c'est à dire que chez nous la
glissade et marges ne pas rentrer dans
le détail ce n'est pas le débat mais
rien qu'au niveau un show loin on
parlait du swing tout à l'heure qu'il
est le plus bas niveau on sera à 11
euros depuis le 1er avril en est à 11
euros 0,1 alors que le suit je crois
pour pas dire bêtise at 10 euros 57 vous
voyez on a largement
anticipée par exemple l'augmentation du
smic qui peut y avoir de 2% et on est
largement au dessus et après chez nous
c'est quand même un ascenseur social les
gens évoluent donc on a surtout après
appuyé sur les niveaux plus élevés ouh
là ça va faire des augmentations de 200
à 300 euros par mois brut n'est pas
négligeable vous avez sentiment qu'avec
l'inflation ce sera ma dernière question
franck delvaux il va falloir une clause
de revoyure et re négocier parce que
très vite ces augmentations vont être
rattrapés par la hausse des prix
non là on est pour nous dans
l'hôtellerie-restauration mma et que
l'inspiration est largement au dessus
mais à un moment on n'est pas les seuls
s'il faut aussi que le gouvernement quel
qu'il soit prenne sa part de
responsabilité il ya aussi les charges
patronales ils peuvent être vus on a
parlé je suis d'accord tout à l'heure de
jeu la trappe à bas salaires jusqu'à 1,6
fois le smic je pense qu'il faut faire
évoluer ce 1,6 et peut-être d'aller
jusqu'aux trois fois le 6 dans les
réductions de type loi fillon l'a aussi
oui il ya des choses à faire évoluer il
faut un peu regardée de tous les côtés
donc on entend la la question des
cotisations le coût de travail merci
beaucoup franck delvaux ce coup de
travail on sait systématique tous les
c'est normal les les chefs d'entreprise
le paye 1 et donc il a il a forcément un
coût est ce que c'est les deux qu'il
faut faire en même temps parce que c'est
pas ça la solution baisser encore les
cotisations tout en augmentant le smic
mais tout d'abord eu ce joli au niveau
du smic ya plus de cotisations
patronales tout savoir d'accord c'est à
dire qu'on a pris la mauvaise habitude
en france on dit toujours que la france
se réforme pas mais on est les champions
du monde des allègements de cotisations
sociales on est les champions du monde
toutes catégories confondues à la grèce
elle a trouvé les cotisations vieillesse
encore à faire voilà levé pour essayer
d'arriver
en cinq ans oui enfin avec des petites
d'ambiguïté sur cotisations salariales
cette fois-ci voyez ce que je veux dire
d'accord donc le comment dire le le
problème qu'on a parce que la part des
salaires dans la valeur ajoutée que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure vous depuis 15
ans a pas bougé nommé faut savoir qu'en
france tout s'est joué dans les années
80 c'est dans les années 90 sur
d'austérité
ça je ne suis pas d'accord
480 tournant de la rigueur en 4 3 3 on
est une chute
la part des salaires dans la valeur
ajoutée a augmenté de 5 points suite à
la crise dans les années 70 ça va
augmenter la part des profits avaient
baissé on a une hostilité très brutal la
part des salaires a baissé deux fois
plus vite plus fortement je souhaitais
rond 83-88 tout s'est joué en quatre ans
que sous thatcher pour est ce que je
veux dire et depuis on est à ce niveau
très bas et un niveau qui est quand même
2,3 points en dessous en moyenne des
trente glorieuses à me dire c'est pas
beaucoup de 3 points mais c'est énorme
d'autant qu'on est confrontés à un
paradoxe des profits si je puis me
permettre
quand on fait de l'austérité salariale
ça comprime la demande globale ça
comprime l'activité des entreprises et
donc quelque part les profits des
entreprises sont pas forcément mieux
même si même s'ils peuvent son
jeu vous permet
tout à fait
mais voilà mais est donc alors le
problème qu'on a avec les allègements de
x-ore qu en allemagne vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure à juste titre enfin en
allemagne on va augmenter le salaire
minimum d'un quart mais bon peut-être un
peu plus bas que le nôtre ben là ils
vont passer largement au-dessus royaume
uni
le salaire minimum la mode un peu
partout dans le monde et d'augmenter le
salaire minimum en espagne au portugal
joe biden avait prévu de le doubler oui
ce que j'ai dit alors je termine sur un
point les libéraux ce qu'ils font c'est
ce que vous propose à nouveau à
l'occasion de ces élections ils disent
on touche x sur un minimum par contre en
fait les libéraux qui d'habitude aime
pas les dépenses publiques bien cela
n'est poursuivi classer les femmes à
l'aise de cotisation les cotisations ya
pas que ça il a pris une d'activité la
prime d'activité échec
le volet
est calculé en fonction des revenus des
ménages 40% des smicards ne touche pas
la prime de crise et alors il ya
l'argument de la compétitivité mais il
faut savoir que les secteurs qui en
france
vers ce délai les deux millions de
personnes et 12 minutes 12 % de salariés
en fait ce sont massivement dans les
secteurs qui sont pas exposés à la
concurrence à la concurrence
internationale dans la métallurgie je
parle sous le contrôle d'un syndicaliste
mais dans les grandes entreprises
exportatrices en fait on parle très peu
au smic mais ce que dire donc l'argument
même de la compétitivité ne fonctionne
pas donc il ya vraiment lieu là de mon
point de vue de réenclencher est alors
un dernier point quand on fait parce que
contrairement à ce qui est évoqué tout à
l'heure il ya déjà défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires et mais quand on
fait ça en fait les libéraux font d'une
pierre deux coups non seulement ils
n'augmentent pas le salaire minimum très
bien mais le salaire pour l'entreprise
mais en plus ils assèchent les
ressources de la protection sociale mais
ce que j'ai à dire sa part des
socialistes et c est donc après on peut
dire non seulement on n'a pas augmenté
les salaires battre on peut dire que les
moyens de la financer
non mais c'est fâcheux tout à fait
d'accord il ya bien un premier enjeu qui
est la protection sociale c'est bien
beau à chaque fois de les toucher aux
cotisations puis après on vient nous
expliquer qu'il faut faire
l'assurance chômage parce que parce
qu'on a des difficultés en un déficit on
est dans un moment de pandémie donc
qu'il faut réformer ya les moyens on va
ravaux il faut les moyens pour l'hôpital
derrière on nous parle déjà de la
réforme des retraites parce qu' alors
que le corps nous dit qu'il ya plus trop
de problème d'ailleurs d'argent mais il
faut aller faire ça et parfois
d'ailleurs prendre de l'argent pour le
mettre ailleurs enfin on en entend tous
tout sur sa donc la protection sociale
c'est vraiment un vrai sujet et puis moi
je reviens une seconde sur ce que le le
collègue du patronat a pu lui a pu nous
dire ils nous disent souvent en à cette
tendance de dire l'état nous aide pas
assez enfin à la base le pouvoir d'achat
et les salaires c'est quand même pas de
la responsabilité de l'état en premier
que l'état soit là c'est des entreprises
elle a donné un coup de main sur un
moment
exceptionnel on a eu la pandémie on à la
guerre en ukraine il ya un événement
exceptionnel ou la réceptionner dans les
entreprises sur le coût du travail vous
dit ça suffit pas le coût du travail ça
suffit
ça suffit c'est surtout que avant tout
le pouvoir d'achat ça se négocie dans
les négociations annuelles obligatoires
en entreprise et c'est avant tout quand
même le rôle des entreprises même s'il
peut y avoir autre chose et aujourd'hui
non seulement à l'heure je disais qu'il
faut passer par une revalorisation du
smig mais il faut aussi passer et ça
s'est fait dans certains secteurs comme
comme celui qu'on vienne aut d'évoquer
mais on doit avoir des négociations de
branche aussi parce qu'il faut que les
conditions de travail alors sur les
alors sur l'attractivité et au canton
par un problème de recrutement
évidemment parfois se poser il faut
aussi se poser la question quand même de
quelles sont les conditions de travail
et quel est le salaire ça peut quand
même avoir une première explication mais
il faut pas oublier qu'aujourd'hui
encore on a près de 70 branches dans
notre pays où les premiers niveaux de
rémunération à vous attendre encore en
dessous du smi ont retrouvé votre
collègue laurent berger de la cfdt je ne
sais pas si vous lui avez parlé de ça
mais cette question là le préoccupe
particulièrement non seulement il ya des
gens qui touchent pas le smic dans notre
pays mais il ya aussi le problème
d'aller au delà dans les revalorisations
salariales du smic le tout dans un
contexte d'inflation écoutez le il était
sur notre plateau dans audition publique
lundi dernier oui le smic il faudrait il
faut le revaloriser parce qu'il ya une
inflation mais ce qu'il faut c'est
revaloriser l'ensemble des greer parce
que l inflation et là ya une
responsabilité du patronat et ce qui va
se passer au 1er mai est inédit on n'a
jamais eu autant de branches
professionnelles dont le début des
grilles va être en soule en dessous de
ce pic sa misère combat mais ça n'a
jamais autant la revalorisation du smic
qui est bienvenu c'est perdre et perdre
y compris des temps des branches où on a
fait des négociations
depuis le mois d'octobre novembre et
avec des hauts des augmentations
salariales obtenu 7 a pas été le cas
malheureusement toutes les branches et
bien il faudra revenir bien que le
village est un nécessité de clause de
retour d'une certaine manière donc il va
falloir que dans toutes les branches bon
ça on allait là dessus et moi j'ai vécu
ce que je souhaite c'est que le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit eh bien ils
imposent aux branches professionnelles
dans les six mois d'avoir des
négociations pour que leurs minima de
branche ne soit pas inférieur au smic
voilà d'accord avec ça question
complètement d'accord évidemment je les
dis il fallait que qu'on puisse
revaloriser l'ensemble des branches et
on doit faire des négociations la dent
mais je voulais juste aussi revenir en
un mot attention au chiffrage sur les
augmentations dans certains secteurs on
a eu 12 13 14 15 % d'augmentation il
faut savoir que les premiers niveaux
étant en dessous du smic des personnes
ont pu facilement ont pas eu forcément
15%
la moyenne oui puis des fois et puis
même quand vous êtes en dessous du smic
comme vous avez une compensation pour
essayer de d'expliquer ce que vient de
dire laurent berger on nous voit là on
n'est pas des économistes le smic pour
nous c'est légal le taux horaire le smic
on peut gagner moins que le smic c'est
ce qu'il explique et donc les
revalorisations il faut cesser ici parce
que c'est on rajoute les primes c'est ça
la prime d'activité pour arriver au smic
est bien obligé de rajouter des
compléments salariaux donc voilà c'est
ça des compensations pour arriver
jusqu'aux grilles ils échapperont à
l'indexation sur l'inflation donc il il
ya toute une série de gens qui ne
pourront pas voir automatiquement avec
la revalorisation
donc j'ai moi un e-mail qui ont enlevé
leurs errements techniques qui auront
leurs salaires encore inférieure à
l'augmentation du smic d'augmentation du
smic alors assez piégeuse et les pièges
jobs pour les gens qui sont en dessous à
des pièges aussi pour les gens qui sont
légèrement au dessus puisque tous tout
tout tout seul au dessus ça se construit
répond bien comprendre on peut les nier
c'est très loin du smic parce qu on
arrive enfin quelques uns des primes
enfin on gagne pas moins du smig mais si
vous avez une grille de salaire qui est
à 7 8 % en dessous du smig comme le smig
est légal votre employeur vous verse une
compensation pour vous donner le smic
sauf que quand vous avez importations
bien des primes c'est ça non c'est une
compensation salariale pour arriver au
smic qui est inquiet le salaire et les
battre mais le salaire n'est pas au smic
et donc quand vous avez une augmentation
de 16%
la compensation de 8% comme ont versé
pour arriver au smic elle disparaît et
donc votre augmentation réelle sur la
fiche de paye elle est plus de 8% c'est
là tout le tout le biais qui peut y
avoir sur l' annonce de chiffrage est
fraîche mathieu ce qui est dangereux
aussi dans la période actuelle où on
voit cette accélération incroyable de
l'inflation c'est de se cristalliser
uniquement sur lequel la question du
smic la question des salaires c'est
effectivement la question du smic bien
sûr parce que voilà mais ça n'est pas
que deux le problème du snow qu'on a
bien compris qu en co2 au delà
sur l'ensemble de béré salariale et
surtout l'ensemble de la grille des
salaires
et donc c'est pour ça que la question
des négociations au sein des branches
est extrêmement importante et que la
l'état un devoir d'un site et d'un site
est peut-être à conditionner pourquoi
pas certaine m va conditionner certaines
baisses d'impôts cet appartement à la
remise en quelles sont les outils que
possèdent les pouvoirs publics on va
voir qui sera élu pour obliger les
entreprises à augmenter les salaires du
smic conditionner
certaines aides conditionnées certain
émoi latrines mcgraw-hill conditionné
pourquoi pas des délais des baisses
d'impôt c'est
en tout cas tout une partie des aides
qui ont été attribués pendant qu'on vit
l'aide aux entreprises dieu sait s'il y
en a en france qu'on peut trouver quand
même une façon de les conditionner
christophe ramaux oui sire que
les libéraux ne cesse de cendres est de
voir dans ton dans l'oeil de mire le
coût du travail enfin ça quand même
maintenant falloir s'interroger sur le
coût du capital oui ce que je veux dire
parce que c'est que c'est comme ça
je considère qu'aujourd'hui en france
globalement il peut y en avoir dans
certains secteurs tout peut-être des et
ciblée bien sûr mais globalement on a
fait de l'austérité salariale d'accord
parce que parce qu'on a fait libre
échange parce qu'on a fait la fille
nancy b réalisé tout se tient messoudi
facultaire ya par exemple un problème de
coût du travail est-ce qu'on peut vais
essayer de différencier vous dites il ya
encore un problème du coût du travail en
france est une comparaison par rapport
aux autres pays n'est pas rapportée par
secteurs de métiers vous dit si c'est
globalement globalement on a un problème
aujourd'hui beaucoup de travail global
et donc et donc il ya besoin de retour
donc tout fait il regarde je veux faire
le tri un très beau de très gros
l'horizon baisser les cotisations c'est
pas forcément c'est un piège redoutable
sélection parce que vous a séché la
cancel avec la bête vous affamer la
pêche et la protection sociale et dont
vous asseyez la protection sociale à
condition de femme non mais c'est ça
n'est pas ce n'est pas un piège si en
face vous réformes et une partie de la
protection sociale même chose dont 65
ont rythmé que vous qui connaissez bien
à la retraite a secoué le monde du
travail est ce qu'on peut leur faire
confiance
aux employeurs et aux syndicats du
patronat pour jouer jeu parce que de
toute façon ces négociations elles vont
se fermer au sein des brouilles et c'est
pour ça que même si on a vu que certains
rapports de force s'inversent parce que
voilà et du rythme en la restauration
est un bon exemple mais on voit ailleurs
ça patine ça coince da coiffure ça
marche très mal les négociations le
bâtiment où chaque coup sourire la
boucherie la boulangerie d'autres
secteurs aussi donc est ce qu ils vont
jouer le jeu il ya une prise de
conscience ou entendre pour cette 2e
c'est plus compliqué le le rôle de
l'état c'est d'inciter et de trouver les
bonnes incitations
à la tenue de ces de ces négociations de
branche c'est son rôle et c'est pour ça
que encore une fois je dis s'accrocher
seulement au smic c'est illusoire parce
que ça ne règle en rien le problème des
salaires en france et ça ne règle en
rien la catastrophe de pouvoir d'achat
qu'on va qu'on va avoir dans les
prochains mois parce que vous avez une
impression aujourd'hui à 5 dans deux
mois je ne sais pas si elle est à 6 ou
7% et le bon créneau dj qu'elle risque
d'être caduques ses hausses de salaires
attrape il faut voir qu'une partie des
hausses de salaires qui ont été accordés
dans un donjon toujours entreprises
elles sont déjà grignoté auxquels sont
déjà un caduque donc ça va être le sujet
majeur qui va être sur la table du quel
que soit le président de la république
qui arrive la première chose c'est
l'ouverture voilà d'une grande
conférence est aussi à vous remettre au
film la table en parler de pouvoir
d'achat on peut pas parler de pouvoir
d'achat sûr on parle pas de partage de
la valeur ajoutée enfin tout à l'heure
vous en parliez mais c'est capital alors
on l'avait d'ailleurs mis dans l'agenda
social du gouvernement
on s'est arrêté à un seul sujet qui a
été le fait de favoriser la
participation et l'intéressement dans un
plus grand nombre d'entreprises
tout à fait d'ailleurs pour la cftc on
était plutôt plutôt favorables sur ça
mais le partage de la valeur ça peut pas
s'arrêter simplement au point de
d'améliorer ou de diffuser plus
largement l'intéressement et la
participation il ya tout de série ont
parlé des écarts de salaires c'est un
vrai sujet il ya aussi l'économie moi je
suis très sensible à ce que vous avez
dit fin à la série sait depuis très très
longtemps on parle aussi de la montée en
gamme on parle de relocalisation de
réindustralisation il faut y aller sur
des secteurs et d'ailleurs on entre
dedans choisir certains avec le
gouvernement sur des secteurs de haute
technologie de haute valeur ajoutée et
si on investit dans des secteurs comme
ça ce sont des secteurs qui demandent
plus de compétences et donc des salariés
mieux rémunérés qui ont accès à ces
produits là cercle vertueux que je
défends depuis très longtemps d'accord
il est d'augmenter les salaires et c'est
la priorité à l'agenda du prochain
président ou de la présidente
peut-être une dernière question pour
conclure ce débat oui vous lire ajouté
déjà quelque chose pour faire face à
l'inflation il ya une règle simple qui a
très bien fonctionné c'est la déflation
enfin c'est là c'est le b à ba vous
savez durant les trente glorieuses
la mauvaise blague
on avait de l'inflation s'était pas la
catastrophe vers alain stationner
dénommé durant les trois jours une
station est nommé durant les troubles
l'image est belle et tous les salaires
qui suivra les pas dans une situation
d'hyper inflation n'est pas parce que la
principale cause de l'inflation la
principale juste mais justement il y
avait un ratio 4 5% par an et vous allez
les salaires augmenter plus et on savait
très bien mais le minutes l'économie a
dit attention on pourrait aller vers ce
qui est arrivé en 1973 le choc pétrolier
le la stagflation c'est à dire en gros
parce que une croissance en berne et
la plus âgée des chiffres rouges pour
justifier le fait trop va pas augmenter
les salaires comment dire la principale
cause de l'inflation c'est les ce sont
des salaires c'est ça la principale
cause de l'inflation or les salaires
aujourd'hui ils sont comprimées par le
libre échange la pression du libre
échange la finance libéralisée qui fait
que les travailleurs sont pas en mission
par le poids du chômage qui fait que les
travailleurs sont pas obligation de
force même le contexte joue sur une
infection ponctuelle liée en allemagne
bien sûr mais l'innovation ponctuel mais
structurellement on n'est pas dans une
situation où là il ya là c'est différent
que vous évoquez alors vous aurez de la
faire là dessus a passé telle existe
cette spirale nous guette la stagnation
ou pas attention il va falloir piloter
sa prudemment il va falloir contraire on
augmente les salaires parce que c'est la
principale cause de l'indexation des
salaires est effectivement la très
mauvaise idée sur les clics l'indexation
des salaires sur l'inflation
c'est effectivement la très mauvaise
idée du pouvoir d'achat mais on vous
rassure pour la belgique pour nous
charmer deux corps non je dis je dis
qu'il va y avoir une baisse massive du
pouvoir d'achat est effectivement que
l'indexation oui j'étais vraiment fini
et donc que permet pour voilà que pour
palier cette baisse historique du
pouvoir d'achat l'indexation des
salaires sur l'inflation et sans doute
pas la bonne idée parce que vous allez
avoir cette boucle prix salaires qui
risque de s'enclencher on fait le
décompte des faits dans lequel est dans
le québec c'est bien on voit voilà il ya
des lignes de fracture chacun se fera
son opinion merci beaucoup qu'on a été
très clair sur ces négociations
salariales en cours et les propositions
dans le débat présidentiel merci à vous
merci j'ai trouvé dit sur le plateau des
cp on va s'arrêter à présent sur la
situation en ukraine avec une grande
spécialiste de la russie marie mendras
ce qui va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant alors que l'ukraine
appelle ses habitants à évacuer
immédiatement l'est du pays avant une
possible offensive majeure de l'armée
russe que sait-on de la stratégie de
vladimir poutine et on a dit lui même
une de stratégie le kremlin connaît-il
des dissensions au sommet du pouvoir on
a plein de questions à lui poser comme
l'expliquent ce sujet thibault enoch
regarder
si on vous invite marie madras c'est que
vous connaissez le pouvoir russe parker
et que nous avons tous été frappés au
coeur justement par lui dans le massacre
de butch a révélé au monde stupéfie et
interroge quelle mécanique a pu amener
le régime de vladimir poutine à
perpétrer de tels crimes de guerre alors
que l'armée russe prépare une nouvelle
offensive au donbass le temps presse en
france aussi où l'on s'apprête à voter
ça fait 20 ans que vladimir poutine est
un criminel de guerre aujourd'hui la
seule mesure c'est l'embargo sur le gaz
et le pétrole russe on est en train
d'être entraînés dans un conflit alors
qu'on aurait pu le régler et qu on peut
encore le régler par une position
intelligente c'est à dire tout
simplement la neutralité de l'ukraine
marie madras dans cette ambivalence
récurrentes vous avez choisi votre camp
la politologue au cnrs professeur à
sciences po et spécialiste du pouvoir
russe que vous êtes n'admet aucune
complaisance à son égard nous avons un
problème en france sur cette étrange
justification d'une violence extrême
utilisé par un dictateur sous prétexte
que parce que il est le successeur d'un
empire d'il ya plus de 100 ans
ils auraient quelque part à un droit ou
une sorte de justification émotive
romantique c'est insupportable ce regard
tranchant vous pousse à mettre
régulièrement des coups de pied dans la
fourmilière en février dernier déjà
avant l'invasion russe vous appeliez
l'europe à sortir de sa torpeur il est
totalement inenvisageable de vouloir
imposer à l'ukraine ou à la biélorussie
ou la moldavie une troisième voie on ne
peut pas être neutre dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui sur le continent européen
ce n'est pas possible avec le régime
poutine au pouvoir en russie le régime
poutine un pouvoir rendu sourd aveugle
selon vous de plus en plus rigides et
isolées statufié presque comme le visage
de son leader mais aussi à pleurer dit
vous d'une grande peur qu'ils se nomment
la démocratie
la bonne nouvelle si l'on peut dire
c'est que vous le jugez ce pouvoir
vulnérables à ce titre vous surveiller
le comportement des élites russes de
plus en plus atterré écrivez-vous par
cette dérive alors marie madras poutine
peut-il perdre la main tandis que se
dessine la perspective d'une guerre
d'usure et que le président et l'inscrit
à une nouvelle fois critiqué aujourd'hui
l'indécision des européens l'europe doit
elle aller plus loin l'ukraine doit l
entrée dans l'union et vladimir poutine
devra t'il un jour être jugé
bonsoir marie mendras bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau vous avez
signé il ya quelques jours une tribune
dans le monde importante intitulé la
folle guerre en ukraine annonce sa
fracture de la dictature russe d'autres
voilà ça c'est le titre de la version
web les mots sont très forts on va y
revenir mais on va évidemment commencer
par ce qui a saisi d'effroi le monde
entier les massacres butch à au
nord-ouest de kiev des corps ligoté qui
laisse penser que l'armée russe s'est
livré aux pires exactions des femmes
violées aussi alors il ya des enquêteurs
qui commencent à récolter des preuves
sur place évidemment des témoignages
rapportés par des journalistes est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment
que ce qui s'est passé la marque un
tournant dans le conflit oui absolument
c'est à dire que je pense que les
exactions il y en a eu ailleurs on va en
découvrir d'autres mais le fait que
cette situation abominable et été
découverte avec un petit peu de retard
au moment du retrait des troupes russes
et que ces tensions en plus une ville
qui n'est pas très loin de la capitale
kiev
montre que là on est vraiment passé dans
un autre stade et ce qui m'inquiète
énormément
c'est la façon dont les autorités russes
d'abord continuer à être dans le déni
ces images là les russes les ont vus ou
c'est impossible certains ces images de
boudhha des images de boudhha le
téléspectateur russe ne les voit pas en
revanche ce que fait le pouvoir c'est de
transformer ces images et de prétendre
que ça a été une mise en scène de leur
désir y est à des russes qui d'ailleurs
maintenant ont été complètement mise à
mal par les vidéos satellite à magrie et
puis et puis en plus tout cela est
tellement ridicule parce que tous ces
corps vont être examinés par des
médecins
il ya quand même une
une science médico légiste donc la
vérité sera faite sur chacun d'eux
chacune de ces exactions alors pourquoi
est ce que le pouvoir et notamment le
ministre des affaires étrangères à 7,7
cette incroyable
culot de nous dire que tout ça est un
montage et que ce sont des des acteurs
russes mon interprétation est
que cette dictature est très malade si
elle en est là c'est à dire que elle
jette ou par dessus bord et qu'ils sont
dans un compte allemand baird oui quitte
à tout perdre parce que là ils vont tous
être bien entendu poursuivi pour crimes
de guerre
peut-être de crimes de génocide
ils le savent donc ils sont dans la
fuite en avant total et je pense qu'ils
ne sont même pas capables d'avoir une
stratégie pour dans un mois dans deux
mois dans à vous expliquer au fond qu'il
n'y a plus de stratégie il le dit
lui-même une stratégie sur ce qu'on a vu
a dit père petit je pense qu'il inquiète
pas une stratégie ce que vous décrivez
des commandants militaires
complètement laissés à eux mêmes très
peu coordonnés qui manquent de tout on a
l'impression qu'il ya le début d'une
vraie difficulté au sein de l'armée oui
et maintenant les les instituts
spécialisés dans le suivi de la guerre
et des ong arrive quand même à une
conclusion
incroyable enfin un bilan incroyable au
bout de six semaines
c'est que il y aurait donc plus de vingt
mille
victimes dans les rangs de l'armée russe
et 20% de ces tués seraient des
officiers dont un certain nombre de
généraux donc c'est un échec
patent et on a l'impression que pour
répondre à cet échec au lieu de tenter
de négocier et de trouver peut-être une
issue est bien le pouvoir poutinien
se referme sur lui-même est parti pour
une violence toujours plus extrêmes
alors les russes vivent pétrifié par la
violence de la propagande écrivez vous
dans cette tribune ils ne sont pas
servis mais sidéré et vous dites qu'un
facteur clef dans l'issue du conflit
c'est le comportement des élites vous
avez beaucoup de contacts en russie
décrivez-nous ce qu'ils comprennent
leurs réactions leur état d'esprit
satellite politique s'était vite
économiques parfois proches du pouvoir
alors bien entendu je n'étudie pas le
clan dirigeants le clan dirigeants il
n'est pas étudia bhl et si on les écoute
parler tout est mensonge donc pourquoi
aller disserter sur les mensonges de
lavrov
ou de poutine ou d'un autre ce qui
m'intéresse depuis des années et ce qui
m'a permis vraiment je pense d'avoir
une ouverture sur ce régime plus
intéressante c'est ce que j'appelle les
élites professionnelles les gens comme
vous et moi des gens qui ne travaillent
pas dans les cercles du pouvoir qui ne
sont pas de riches oligarques mais qui
sont de
cette classe moyenne éduquée qui ont des
postes importants dans la société
dans un domaine ou un autre et qui
depuis des années se sentent de plus en
plus
mis de côté et surtout de plus en plus
en difficulté pour maintenir leur niveau
de vie et continuer à faire leur métier
d'écrivain qu'elles sont atterrés c'est
la wii je pense parce que jusqu'au
dernier jour
ils étaient tous comme nous comme il
n'arrivait pas à concevoir une guerre de
destruction totale quand on ne peut pas
concevoir quelque chose on se dit
poutine fait comme d'habitude il fait
son chantage écrit très fort mais il ne
va pas le faire et en fait je pense
qu'au fond d'eux mêmes il comprenait que
si poutine passer à l'acte pour eux
c'était la terreur et donc ils sont très
nombreux
c'est cyrus classe moyenne élite
professionnelle à quitter le pays depuis
déjà 2010 2011 mais depuis six semaines
c'est par dizaines de milliers tant
qu'ils arrivent à sortir du pays c'est
pour ça que souvent ils vont vers des
destinations où il ya encore des vols
comme par exemple
la turquie et c'est désespérant enfin de
se dire qu'on va avoir cet exode est que
au fond les russes vivent la guerre
aussi justement le quotidien de la
classe moyenne en russie quel est il
d'un point de vue des sanctions des
effets sont très lourds très pénible on
s'est rué on a vu ces images sur les
cartes bancaires retirer de l'argent
dans les machines il n'y a plus
d'économie n'y a plus d'argent non c'est
à dire que pour les personnes qui n'ont
pas de réserves cachées qui n'ont pas de
famille ou d'amis à l'étranger vers
lequel ils pourront peut-être se tourner
pour le moment ils sont otages d'une
dictature qui leur impose la guerre
économique chez eux la répression qui en
plus les fait vivre dans une propagande
infernal ce que non seulement elle est
mensongère mais elle est très violente
quand on regarde les informations
télévisées
des images qui sont montrés qu'ils ne
seraient jamais montré sur nos écrans de
télévision en france ou en europe donc
c'est les ya beaucoup beaucoup de
familles qui savent pas comment elles
vont arriver jusqu'à la fin du mois il
ya une inflammation une inflation très
forte alors vous vous décrivez poutine
comme un homme isolé et coupé de la
réalité qui n'écoute absolument plus
personne à part lui même
avait il ya quelques rares témoignages
de personnalités qui ont pu lui parler
qui raconte ça quelqu'un qui est prêt au
fonds allait aller jusqu'au bout je
voudrais qu'on dise un mot quand même de
la réponse des européens
largement en deçà quand même des
attentes du président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky qui a dit sa colère
hier en visioconférence à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies il a même
parlé d'un décision ce matin c'était
lors d'une adresse au parlement
irlandais a écouté
maintenant quand il y à des discussions
sur les sanctions contre la fédération
de russie je ne peux pas entendre de
doute je ne peux pas voir d'indécision
après tout ce que nous avons vécu en
ukraine
après tout ce que les troupes russes ont
fait même maintenant alors que le monde
connaît déjà tous les crimes de guerre
de la russie contre notre peuple
nous devons persuader même certaines
entreprises européennes de quitter le
marché russe
voilà ce soir ce qui est en discussions
c'est un embargo sur le charbon dont
l'europe est évidemment beaucoup moins
dépendante que que du gaz russe les pays
baltes eux ont décidé de passer de se
passer du gaz russe est ce que les
européens ont la main qui tremble pour
sanctionner poutine est ce que lui qui
ne connaît que la force ne nous regarde
pas un peu comme faible
maintenant tout cela est dépassé c'est à
dire que nous avons et nous continuons
de voter des sanctions très très dur les
américains aussi les japonais les
australiens donc le l'économie russe va
être petit à petit étranglé suffisante
vous vous diriez puisque la grande
question c'est l'embargo est question de
temps le gaz en fait je dirais que tout
est question de temps c'est à dire que
les russes ils vont chercher à gagner du
temps pour que la résistance ukrainienne
s'épuise pendant ce temps il faut que
nous européens en armes davantage cette
résistance faut qu'on aille beaucoup
plus vite et plus fort dans les
sanctions c'est à dire étranglé
l'économie russe bien sûr les élites
mais que aussi la population comprenne
qui a plus d'issue dans les semaines qui
viennent dans les dirai dans les deux
semaines qui viennent parce que la
politique de poutine semble être de
continuer les massacres les
bombardements aveugles sur des villes
sans possibilité d'avoir des convois
humanitaires et cela pour le président
ukrainien on comprend bien que c'est un
dilemme absolument effroyable les les
européens des pays de l'otan depuis le
début sont prises au piège
puisque s'il
participe directement à la veine comme
et les gérants des recettes elles sont
voilà le l'otan s'engage
dans la guerre donc il faut vraiment que
que notre rythme après soit en tout
petit frère api pour terminer d'un mot
marais mandras vous avez vu que le
premier ministre polonais extrêmement
dur avec emmanuel macron elle lui
reproche de négocier avec vladimir
poutine il a dit combien de fois avez
vous négocié avec poutine qu'avez vous
obtenu on ne débat pas on ne négocie pas
les criminels de guerre personne n'a
jamais négocié avec hitler il pas un peu
raison de dire ça oui bien sûr il a
raison de dire ça aujourd'hui
quand emmanuel macron a commencé à
négocier c'était encore à l'automne
dernier mais je pense qu'effectivement
lire les jeux aux criminels de guerre
prononcé le montant de 2 de maintenir
l'espoir très ténue que on peut parler à
un homme qui a perdu complètement le
sens des proportions c'est peut-être en
effet l'encourager dans son délire et
dans le recours à la force extrême mais
quelle qu'ait été la vie de l'attitude
d' emmanuel macron des autorités à
bruxelles de du chanceux les choletais
je pense que les jeux étaient faits
depuis déjà le mois de décembre dernier
merci beaucoup merci marie mendras ce
vous rester avec moi je renvoie à la
lecture de ce papier de cette tribune
dans le monde c'était le 4 avril dernier
vous pouvez évidemment la trouver en
ligne allez c'est l'heure du scan on va
passer aux cris de la campagne à quatre
jours du premier tour avec nos
chroniqueurs tout de suite
mais avant les dons il y a les deux bras
de fatalité au grand remplacement et de
la mole vous propose le rose delmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
aux exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur la russie à cela pas de mystère
c'est de vol
un éditorialiste politique ce soir
bonsoir thomas legrand et je suis mieux
log mariette darrigrand qui dirige
l'observatoire des mots bonsoir et
stéphane blakowski on commence avec vos
l'oeil de blacko atterré par qui par
quoi ce soir alors on commence à voir le
bout de cette campagne en tout cas de la
campagne du premier tour donc il est
temps pour les candidats qui sont sous
les 5% de commencer à se trouver des
excuses
évidemment donc prenons un exemple on
est tous d'accord pour dire que
l'écologie quand même parmi les
préoccupations importantes des français
donc comment se fait-il que yannick
jadot soit toujours sous les 5% bon on
pourrait dire sa boîte un peu de sa
faute oui mais pas seulement c'est aussi
la faute des médias écouter quand on
voit que le climat a occupé trois pour
cent du débat public ces dernières
semaines on peut aussi s'interroger sur
notre responsabilité collective
collectivement les médailles d'or mais
oui la vôtre comme candidat de
l'écologie puis ça vient boulevard
jeanne un boulevard à on verra dimanche
boulevard se cherche des excuses quoi
d'autre à voir il y aussi les excuses
des sondages peut-être que vous souvenez
que nicolas dupont aignan avait presque
atteint les 5 % en 2010 est hélas un
ennemi pour cent seulement dans les
sondages alors à qui la faute
même pas de sa faute un nom je pense que
si les bas dans les sondages c'est
surtout à cause des sondages en écoute
je pense que des sondages ont une très
néfaste influence par qu'il condamne à
mort des candidats comme mois al avance
ils font croire qu'il n'y a que deux ou
trois choix possibles alors qu'en vérité
tout est ouvert fondamentalement parce
que ils font croire que l'élection ait
joué et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le
français ne décourage ou alors chacun à
sa bonne raison faudrait peut-être
penser à mobiliser son électorat
et malgré tout cherché à rassembler son
camp même des bonnes nouvelles ça arrive
regarder que la dupont-aignan dans son
camp serait je vis que ce matin vous
avez entendu le pnf donc le parc
national financier ouvre une enquête
dans l' affaire mam crise est donc alors
florian philippot immédiatement ce qu'on
dispute sur facebook vous allez voir il
est entre les deux à la fois il est
content ça le saloir réjouissait de
piqué dans ce camp là et en même temps
n'arrive pas y croire lui qui est
complotistes que la justice soit
indépendante là non il ne revient pas
vraiment une nouvelle absolument
inattendu incroyable qui vient de tomber
ce direct figurez vous que le pnf le
parquet national financier vient
d'annoncer l'ouverture d'une enquête
dans la sphère mckinsey alors c'est une
c tu pars je vais vous dire
que le pnf ouvre une enquête là
maintenant
c'est phénoménal
n'en revient pas ou alors est ce qu'elle
peut avoir une influence sur sur les
résultats d'élections cette attente
l'intérieur du bénef généralement quand
le pen ep semelle de la campagne ça
change de 3 2 3
le point avant le résultat donc cette mi
impossible que ça change à nouveau
d'ailleurs dupont aignan qui était
déprimé retrouve un peu espoir voyez 10
et les élections sont truquées la
victoire de macron est prévue à l'avant
ce live se demande si finalement les
élections sont vraiment aussi truqués
que ça c'est son petit doigt qui lui a
dit mon petit doigt me dit je peux me
tromper que les français en tout cas je
leur dis si vous allez voter massivement
si les 47 millions d'électeurs vont
voter et bien je peux vous dire on peut
déjà sortir emmanuel macron dès le
premier tour ce qui serait un grand et
le premier tour dès le premier tour je
pense qu'ils arrivent à lionel jospin
peut arriver à ma emmanuel macron bon
aux dernières nouvelles emmanuel macron
est toujours le favori dans l'est dans
les sondages mais il reste quatre jours
de campagne alors il faut continuer d'y
croire et on en a besoin d'être motivés
regard des benjamins lucas qui est un
des porte-parole de yannick jadot lui il
y croit encore pourquoi voter yannick
jadot alors qu'il ne sera pas au second
tour il a une bonne raison quoi tout le
monde a repeint sa façade en verre il ya
deux ou trois ans c'est parce que
yannick jadot et les écologistes ont
fait un score historique aux élections
européennes donc si on veut que le
climat pèse dans le débat si on veut
qu'ils aient plus une seule politique
publique qui ne prennent pas en compte
ce qui est bon pour le climat pour la
biodiversité pour l'air que nous
respirons et pour la qualité de nos vies
alors il faut que les écologistes soient
le plus haut possible dimanche et pour
les écologistes le plus haut possible
qu'un bulletin de vote c'est celui
yannick jadot et voilà ils applaudirent
matin de seconde il allait droit 27
c'est gros c'est parfait mais bon lui
les jeunes il en veut mais notre qui
c'est dur quand même je veux lui sait
bien que l'âge n'est pas un critère mais
jean lassalle ou la campagne ça commence
à faire long je crois que ce matin il
était 8h30 il ne savait même plus trop
pourquoi il était candidat on regarde
vous êtes candidat jean lassalle parce
que si je ne me l'avait pas été je
n'aurais pas su pour qui voter vous vous
allez voter pour vous ça on a bien
compris mais est ce que vous pourriez
dire aux français pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
voteraient pour vous oui oui je vais sur
les
campus pas quoi mais je n'ai pas dites
moi d'abord quelques est-ce que vous
portez vous comme priorité dans votre
campagne dans votre candidature il
faudra ce grand pays
voilà c'est un poteau il devrait mieux
je reconnais qu'ils viennent avant 30
chez nous
merci beaucoup stéphane alors thomas ce
soit vous avez auscultée de près cet
écart qui se resserre dans les
intentions de vote entre emmanuel macron
et et marine le pen et si les courbes se
croisent et
c'est la question parce qu'en fait les
courbes haute une trajectoire
intéressante enfin pas très intéressante
pour les milliers de maquereau est
plutôt intéressant pour emmanuel macron
était il faut le rappeler
début mars il était vers 30 31 pour ça
on le voit sur le jeu sur le graphique
et marine le pen était même à 14 5% et
ça c'était l'effet de la guerre il ya
une ya eu un effet général en chef et
voilà effet drapeau effet général en
chef et puis on revient est ce qu'on
revient à la normale ou est-ce que ces
courbes ont un moteur différent quel est
le moteur calé l'énergie qui fait que
ses courbes descente où monte on arrive
aujourd'hui 27 et 22 finalement à un
étiage
alors c'est avant décembre alors le voit
pas sur la cour mais avant
jusqu'en et caen caen avant que eric
zemmour soit soit candidat et avant
qu'ils aient la guerre c'est à peu près
l'étiage
on y est sauf que sauf que le l'effet
vote utile bat son plein et
marine le pen pourrait monter encore un
peu et si on poursuit les courbes et ça
pourrait se croiser alors il reste que
deux jours classe alors il reste que
deux jours de campagne mais il reste que
y reste quatre jours avant dimanche et
la question est de savoir si ça va se
croiser ou pas et jean luc mélenchon
derrière montrent aussi et donc il ya
deux vote utile possible la gauche pour
jean luc mélenchon et la droite pour
marie de la marine le pen et le problème
de jean luc mélenchon sait qu'il a
beaucoup moins de réserves que que
marine le pen puisque jean luc mélenchon
va faire les poches de yannick jadot qui
sont pas tellement plein vous l'avez dit
blaco une partie des réflexions de jado
votre mac row alors voilà et alors que
marine le pen
à des proches à faire beaucoup plus
pleines celle
d'eric zemmour 10% à peu près 10% 9 ou
10 % ou de réserve de réserve et
il valérie pécresse et valérie pécresse
aussi 10% et donc en fait aujourd'hui on
est on est absolument dans la certitude
et les gens les les soutiens des manuels
macron explique que ça y est on est
arrivé à allah l'étiage d'avant et des
soutiens de marine le pen explique que
non la dynamique est terminée on
continue et on compte les dynamiques
l'impression que la dynamique est quand
même on sait bien que les politiques ce
délai les dynamiques et les les sondages
ce ne sont pas des additions mais ce
sont des dynamiques et c'est très
compliqué à
évaluer et marine le pen joue maintenant
sur sur sept ce vote utile comme jean
luc mélenchon est en fait les les
électeurs sont devenus des stratèges et
c'est pour ça que les c'est pour ça
qu'il n'y il déteste que les hommes
politiques et les candidats déteste les
sondages et disent toujours du mal des
sondages alors que les sondages ce ne se
sont jamais trompés en fait depuis 2007
ne se sont pas trompés parce que nous
pouvons être des stratèges ils veulent
être les seuls stratège mais nous aussi
on a droit d'être laissera t il mais
c'est quand même fascinant quand on voit
27 22 17 c'était comme ça
sauf que c'était plus resserrée avant le
premier tour il ya cinq ans pour mes
droits
oui parce que je veux dire on avait les
trois dans le même ordre mais plus serré
les sens et sans la présence d'éric
on verra en effet les mourmelonnais
alors on va parler d'un mot avec vous
pour terminer mariette c'est un mot qui
se retrouvaient dans la bouche de
plusieurs candidats pas tous mais de
certains ce mot c'est le mot chaos alors
c'est un mot que je suis à la trace
depuis quelques temps plusieurs années
même et qui s'est trouvée dans notre
campagne électorale et moi j'ai un peu
l'impression que c'est une clé de
lecture qui explique les sondages
parfois peut-être qu'il peut être un
indicateur plus fiable je voudrais le
dire alors c'est un mot qui vient des
extrêmes extrême droite d'abord eric
zemmour a été l'un des premiers à
l'employé quand il a parlé du sud france
est donc ce grand désordre immense c'est
le chaos en france bien sûr jean luc
mélenchon s'en est saisie parce que lui
vint nab loin de ce type d' exagération
dans ses effets de tribune donc en
particulier à l'assemblée nationale on a
vu
fustigé la politique du gouvernement sur
les masques sur le passage du ter etc je
crois qu'on a un son
sur lesquels on
vous a vu le publ voilà donc bon mais ça
ça mais là le débat à la hauteur de
l'imagination le cas où tu une hyperbole
marine le pen aussi alors elle ce
qu'elle dit c'est que tout le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron était une
crise une succession de crises qu'a
amené au chaos et sa réélection doit
être un chaos encore plus grand on va
l'écouter justement son quinquennat fut
un immense chaos
donc c'est moi ou il car le gall a dit m
exactement c'est un revient ce mot
systématiquement alors d'abord je crois
qu'il est beau justement il est plus
beau que le déluge les plus beaux que la
chienlit mais c'est un peu la même idée
il est beau parce qu'il est politique il
vient de la poésie n'est pas un mot de
la langue politique aux voyelles d'où
peut-être rêver quand knicks quand
nietzsche disait par exemple il faut
être une étoile dansant au bord du ko
c'est magnifique donc c'est passé aussi
dans la langue de certains intellectuels
edouard glissant par duke à opéra et ça
s'y retrouver dans la loi elle dans la
langue politique bon mais la vraie
raison je crois que c'est parce que
notre époque a mis aussi la radicalité
dans son registre est ce notre campagne
elle se elle est là dessus il faut être
radical même si effectivement on n'est
pas très loin de 2017 mais en cinq ans
le mot radicale aussi est monté donc le
chaos c'est son emblème et puis il y a
eu la télé américaine
il ya eu des épisodes chaotiques le 6
janvier 2021 l'agression du capitole
ensuite la débandade américaine qui
quittent l'afghanistan et ce chaos ce
carrosse en anglais c'est la même chose
le exactement ça a étiré plus qu'un mot
directement c'est en fait notre chaos
tout à fait c'est pas simplement un mot
c'est un écosystème de sémantique c'est
un mythe c'est un grand mythe alors
c'est le mythe de la genèse ah oui dans
l'état hébreu et le tohu bohu en hébreu
c'est exactement la même idée c'est à
dire un bouillonnement les grecs dans
les textes grecs c'est le bouillonnement
il se passe rien c'est absolument
infertiles jusqu'à ce que un dieu et
dans notre tradition dieu avec son verbe
met de l'ordre dans tout ça et là la vie
peut arriver et comment macron alors
saisi de ce mot de cette hyperbole parce
que on a cité les autres et ce qu'ils en
parlent ou s'est alors lui de la guerre
on ne crève le cas aujourd'hui allreal
il est dans le chaos réel de l'ukraine
mais il sait très bien ce que font ses
deux adversaires pour le pour le
deuxième tour marine le pen elle dit je
vais vous protéger du chaos par l'ordre
mélenchon lui il dit bah tant qu on y
est allons-y dans le chaos et on fait
tout exploser un autre monde est
possible donc le président sortant le
président candidat il défie évidemment
il ne prend qu'une de ses dépositions
mais c'est qu'entre les deux il ya une
route c'est ça qu'il qu'il propose il va
nous dit il nous dit continuons la route
elle sera pas facile mais elle sera pas
chaotique donc dimanche je crois que
c'est ça qui va faire l'élection soit la
continuation soit l'explosion soit le
désir de protection
merci en tout cas j'ai appris des choses
sur l'origine de ce mot merci à vous
merci encore marie mendras souhaite la
bienvenue vous le savez sur ce plateau
quand vous le souhaitez merci à vous mes
très chers chroniqueur c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
pour la voir ou la revoir la chaîne
youtube lcp ou le site lcpan tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire avec un
un film de guillaume et stevie je vous
écoute sur tous ces bénévoles au
téléphone à des coupes de la détresse du
pays depuis la crise salutaire très
belle soirée à demain
[Musique]